[Music]
on this Saturday night reflection on
world Holocaust Remembrance Day at a
Time of rising anti-Semitism a Nazi
death camp Survivor message of hope I
can imagine a world where people are
kind to one another as Israel's war
rages on the dire warning about gaza's
largest remaining medical facility
nearing
collapse explicit AI images we are
alarmed by uh the reports of this the
circulation of images the calls for
greater safeguards after obscene deep
fakes of Taylor Swift went viral and
finally paid you can win if you're in
the right the couple who took Air Canada
to court over a flight delay and
won global national with faren Asser
reporting tonight newu Gara good evening
and thanks for joining us today the
world paused reflecting and remember
remembering one of the darkest times in
human history paying tribute to 6
million Jewish people and others
persecuted and murdered by the Nazis
during the second world war today is
international Holocaust Remembrance Day
which also coincides with the 79th
anniversary of the liberation of the
awit burken out camp where more than 1
million Jewish people were killed
Holocaust Survivors and their relatives
held prayers and placed candles during a
ceremony at the site in southern Poland
earlier today global leaders are urging
the rejection of anti-Semitism and hate
in a world that seems to be growing more
divided a synagogue in downtown
frederickton New Brunswick was
vandalized overnight several windows
were shattered with glass littering the
ground police say they're working to
determine whether the synagogue was
targeted Karen liberman takes a closer
look at the state of anti-Semitism in
Canada on this Holocaust Remembrance Day
and how events in the Middle East
continue to fuel hate crimes against the
Jewish
community and that's the only thing I
have of my mom H B has little left to
show from the past but the memories
remain Vivid I was in Hell In aitz which
was truly hell as a holocaust Survivor
watching events in the Middle East
brings her back decades what we see now
is
devastating a worldwide hatred of news
immediately following the October 7th
attack on Israel police in Canada
stepped up Security in Jewish
neighborhoods and around places of
worship noting an uptick in reported
hate crimes between October 7th and
December 17th Toronto's police chief
says there were 988 hate crimes reported
compared to 48 during the same period in
2022 of these incidents more than half
were anti-semitic I have had people
calling me say they're the only Jewish
Family in their School their child is
being spit on they have uh students
etching swastikas into their child's
Locker a Montreal Jewish school was hit
twice by gunfire in November in less
than a week I looked at it not just
literally as someone shooting bullets
through the door of the school but
figuratively someone just shooting a
bullet into this warm beautiful
community and just like shaking us up
for absolutely no reason other than
hatred and
bias University campuses across North
America have become a hot bed for
tension with student classes some
violent like this one at Concordia what
is happening in synagogues in schools at
businesses uh people's homes this is not
Canada the Quran tells me that unless I
respect the people of the book which
includes Jews and Christians and people
of other faith I can't expect for them
to respect me for survivors like bom who
have dedicated ated their lives to
raising awareness about the consequences
of hate a recent Global rise of
anti-Semitism has her wondering we
thought we're doing something but look
what's happening that whatever we did
wasn't enough or wasn't the right thing
Jews had to start identifying themselves
with these yellow badges last year the
Toronto Holocaust museum opened its
doors to the public unveiling a space
dead dedicated to remembrance and
education they're coming here to really
understand the full scope and to hear
Survivor testimony and to learn the rise
of anti-Semitism and the impact that the
Holocaust had on the Jewish Community
bom hopes people take every opportunity
to hear the stories of the past to
prevent history from repeating itself
and I can imagine a world where people
are kind to one another regardless of
color and religion and nationality Karen
liberman Global News
Toronto German Chancellor Olaf scholes
is warning of a rise of the far right in
his country as it marks International
Holocaust Remembrance Day schules says
concerns are growing as right-wing
groups gain significant political
support among Germans including one
party that sparked protest over
Revelations its members took part in a
secret meeting with extremist groups
Mike Armstrong
explains it is a push back against a
party that is growing more than 100,000
people protested in the streets of dorf
Saturday with a warning the alternative
for Germany party they say is getting
stronger this woman says they're sending
a signal the afd won't get into power
that there are too many people against
them there have been protests against
the afd for weeks this was Thursday
night in rostock a city that knew not
only the Holocaust but more recently in
the '90s anti-immigrant riots neo-nazis
burned the homes of migrants to chance
of zig h yeah my we need to finally
stand up and fight against our country
moving more and more to the right she
says the afd is the fifth largest party
in the German Parliament it's polling at
about 20% nationally far right group
campaigns on issues like the cost of
living and environmental policies but it
is also deeply nationalist and
anti-immigration in fact more so each
year now the recent wave of protests was
sparked by a report members of the party
took part in a secret meeting of
far-right extremist groups that included
neo-nazis the policy pushed in the
meeting was called remigration the
expulsion of migrants who've gone to
Germany including naturalized citizens
that would contravene Refugee
conventions and the German
Constitution protesters have pointed out
parallels with Nazi Germany in fact the
secret meeting took place just
kilometers from where the Nazi party
planned its so-called final solution of
the Jewish question I love Germany and I
moved to Germany in the '90s and what
this uh what's happening right now with
the afd is not the Germany I came to and
came for and I'm
disgusted now many are pointing to an
urgency for their message there are
local and Regional elections the eastern
part of the country slated for September
polls in that region put the afd at
about 30% and in the lead Mike Armstrong
Global News
Montreal the fighting in Gaza is showing
no end in sight after three months of
Bloodshed the enclaves health system is
on the brink of
collapse a agency Doctors Without
Borders says gaza's largest remaining
medical facility Nasser hospital is now
now unable to provide critical Medical
Care and that there are few places for
those who need care in Han Yunis to go
Israeli forces have ordered everyone in
certain neighborhoods to get out
including from the
hospital the Hamas run Health Ministry
says
174 Palestinians have been killed in the
past 24 hours and hundreds more have
been wounded as Israel intensifies its
assault one day after the intern ational
court of justice ordered Israel to
prevent genocide in Gaza today the UK
Italy and Finland joined several other
nations including the US and Canada in
pausing funding for the un's relief and
works agency one of the largest
providers of Aid in Gaza 12 agency
members were fired over allegations they
supported and were involved in the
October 7th Hamas
attacks in the Red Sea Yemen's houthi
Rebels have delivered another strike
this time hitting a fuel tanker with
links to the UK they also fired a
missile at a US warship patrolling the
Gulf of Aiden saying it is a response to
American British
aggression as the US campaign Trail
heats up there are fears our Southern
neighbor is becoming less attractive to
Canadians taking on foreign posts
personal safety and health care are high
on the list of concerns the union
representing Canada's Foreign Service
officers is urging Ottawa to take those
issues more seriously part of broader
push to revitalize Canada's diplomatic
core worldwide David Aken
reports the reality and frequency of gun
violence in the United States is
America's major public safety problem
but it's also spooking some Canadian
diplomats there I mean the security
situation in some of these um you know
these places has deteriorated like
you're hearing more um demonstrations
shootings underfunding of police
departments and and all kinds of
problems and we're starting to see it
really affecting our our members on top
of that getting adequate Health Care
coverage has made America a less
attractive spot for diplomatic postings
it adds a layer of stress and
uncertainty and risk frankly that makes
it difficult for people to you know that
makes it harder for people to look at
these postings the healthcare problem is
one affecting the Civil Service in
Canada and around the world after the
government of Canada switched insurance
providers for its employees it's a
switch the new provider itself concedes
overwhelmed its capacity to deal with
claims that's something that's really
got to be straightened out uh before it
gets very serious uh and someone is is
forced to pay uh a fortune for medical
care in the United States we talked
Senator Peter beam spent a career with
global Affairs Canada and now is the
chair of the Senate's Foreign Affairs
committee he led a year-long study to
find ways to revitalize the Foreign
Service it's a service
his committee argues is vital for
Canada's future prosperity and security
this is part of our government this is
part of what we do this is who we
represent we represent a an important
strong diverse country and we do that
abroad and that message has to get out
there to Canadians so it doesn't get
lost in the fog of politics some argue
diplomacy will be even more important to
Canada in an era when the Us and other
allies are questioning traditional
alliances I would say regardless of the
outcoming the election in the United
States but especially if Trump gets
elected we need to massively ramp up
diplomacy ramp ramp up our Armed Forces
ramp up our development assistance
because it's Canada is in for a very
very Rocky ride for the years to come
the trudo government broadly agrees with
calls to revitalize The Diplomatic Corp
but it is still figuring out just how to
do that David aen Global News
Ottawa the long-awaited national inquiry
into foreign interference will finally
kick off public hearings in Ottawa
Monday the same day MPS will return to
Parliament after their winter recess our
Mercedes Stevenson spoke with two
National Security Experts to preview the
inquiry Mercedes how much ground will
the inquiry
cover nethu while the initial hearings
won't get into any of the juicy stuff as
in what actually happened it will still
be an important discussion because it's
going to deal with just how much
information some of which is highly
classified should be released to the
public former thesis director and
National Security adviser to the Prime
Minister dick faden is one of the
experts scheduled to testify this week
faden leads towards more transparency
but this week on the west block he told
me that he's concerned that the inquiry
timeline is simply too short for
commissioner maie Jose hog to properly
study the issue especially now that
there are more countries being looked at
than just China I think she is operating
under a time frame that makes it almost
impossible in my view to deal with all
of these is issues substantively so if I
were the commissioner and I never will
be I would say report at the end of this
year but then ask for another 6 to8
months to complete things we'll probably
be in an election then and nobody will
be paying a great deal of attention it
has been over a year since concerns
about Chinese interference were publicly
revealed experts say it's taken too long
to set up the inquiry and that Canada
could take meaningful action before the
inquiry is over they also point out that
Canada is already behind Alli countries
when it comes to protecting our
elections the United Kingdom Australia
us they have been working on this for
the last 5 10 years we're just beginning
that work there will be a second round
of public hearings in March that's when
the inquiry is expected to take a deeper
dive into the potential interference by
China Russia and India in the 2019 and
the 2021 Canadian Federal elections not
scheduled however to be put under the
microscope in the inquiry Iran this
despite numerous reports of alleged
interference by the Iranian regime with
the Iranian Canadian diaspora and that's
one country that our experts say needs
to be added we'll have more on the show
Neu Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
Mercedes Swift action needed coming up
the calls for stronger legislation after
explicit deep fakes Target the world's
biggest pop
star fake pornographic images of Taylor
Swift spread across social media this
week sounding the alarm about the rise
of advanced AI technology Swift is the
world's biggest pop star so it shows how
anyone can be targeted and with the US
campaign in full swing and our own
federal election on the horizon Mike
Dray looks at the calls for stronger
laws to stop damaging deep
[Music]
fakes she's the biggest pop star in the
world everyone it seems wants a piece of
Taylor Swift hey y'all it's Taylor Swift
here here She is is selling cookware it
certainly sounds like her and explicit
photos that appeared online this week
look like her but none of it is real
it's AI generated deep fake and has
caught the eye of top officials we are
alarmed by uh the reports of this of the
circulation of images that you just laid
out false images to be more exact and it
is alarming the quality of deep pick
Technologies advancing at an alarming
rate comedian George Carlin died in 2008
yet here he is sorry it took me so long
to come out with new material but I I do
have a pretty good excuse I was
dead while his estate is suing the media
company that created it finding who is
responsible for the President Joe Biden
rooc call a bunch of miluk won't be as
easy partly due to the anonymity of the
internet but also because there are only
a handful of US states that have laws
related to AI in Place Canada will be
able to regulate AI platforms with Bill
c27 but it's unlikely to be in place
before next year leaving the owners on
the companies that create the programs
to build safeguards that is a tail of
all this time of capitalism right of the
it is really an arms race right now
between Microsoft Google um uh you know
Amazon the big tech companies uh to try
to create the market share around this
technology um and the result is that
they're cutting corners on uh what I
would call sponsible development or or
ethical development but tech companies
and governments alike will have a hard
time ignoring Tay T's Rabbid fan base
which reacted swiftly to purge social
media of the offensive photos which in
turn prompted Microsoft's CEO to promise
action I think that it's behooves us to
move fast on this it's a Brave New World
out there when it comes to technology we
just have to decide what we want that
world to look like Mike trle Global News
Toronto ahead the couple who
successfully sued Air Canada for
ignoring passeng
[Music]
rights Federal air passenger protection
regulations are meant to compensate
Travelers for flight disruptions but
some Airlines often ignore those rules
so for passengers the only option is to
take those companies to court Heidi petk
spoke to one couple that took on
Canada's biggest
Airline we had a lot of them when Terry
and Vicky Lin Black's Air Canada flight
to New York was cancelled in
2022 the airline blamed crew constraints
due to covid-19 and later rejected their
application for financial compensation
under air passenger protection
regulations it's not cool being just
basically brushed aside the Canadian
Transportation agency offers passengers
recourse but with a current backlog of
almost 65,000 complaints the blacks
thought small claims court might be the
shorter route I honestly thought it
would be much faster a year and a half
later a Nova Scotia adjudicator ordered
Air Canada pay the blacks the amount
owed under the regulations plus interest
and costs almost
$1600 you can win if you're in the right
uh but you have to decide whether the
effort is worth it for you as of this
month there are more Airlines operating
in Canada that now fall under the
regulations including Air Transat
Sunwing and flare that likely means more
potential claims what needs to happen is
far more aggressive enforcement and far
clearer set of rules the Canadian
Transportation agency says it is working
on that using a new process to tackle
its case load and says proposed changes
to the regulations expected later this
year should also help to deal with some
of the the gaps or the shortcomings of
these relatively young regulations that
we enacted in 2019 although the National
Airlines Council of Canada warns what's
on the table including steeper fines
could ultimately hurt Travelers first of
all it will add significant cost to the
air travel system uh two it will have an
impact on Regional connectivity the
blacks hope the decision in their case
sets a helpful precedent for anyone
planning to have their own day in court
the only way they found to get their
compensation Heidi pachic Global News
Windsor Junction Nova
Scotia next miniature Marvel a sneak
peek at what's inside the world largest
[Music]
dollhouse a dollhouse may be something
your children want or say they need but
did you know the largest most famous one
is in the UK it was a gift for Queen
Mary following the first world war and
is on display at Windsor Castle Crystal
ganing shows us its many
Treasures they're miniature but there's
no mistaking The Sovereign scepter orb
and Crown complete with re real Jewels
just three of the uniquely crafted and
spectacular items Furnishing this doll's
house made for the concert of King
George V initially it was intended to
just be a gift to Queen Mary um because
she was very fond of anything that was
miniature she had a great fness for that
type of object but gradually as the
project progressed it became actually
much more serious in purpose and it it
turned into um a showcase for British
craftsmanship imagine this Steady Hand
needed to string this tiny concert piano
or lay the 2,000 tiles that make up the
kitchen floor surely there must have
been a trick to getting actual gem
inside these oh so tiny glass jars
throughout this Edwardian residence
built 100 years ago there are numerous
intricate Creations that Boggle the mind
I hope you can just pick up that there's
a little thread here here um that's been
carefully fed through so this little
flap if I take these scissors off this
little flap comes up and is hinged
properly over 1500 artists Crafts People
and manufacturers contributed to Queen
Mary's dolls house to Mark its Centenary
some of the Miniatures are being
displayed alongside their fullscale
counterparts at Windsor Castle when it
was first shown in 1924 100 years ago it
was on display at the Empire exhibition
and of course there it was seen by a
huge number of people another Royal
house that continues to draw a crowd but
not to worry this one is also guarded by
a knight in tiny Shining Armor Crystal
ganing Global News
London and that is global national for
this Saturday night I'm Nara tonight's
your Canada is the VII Memorial in
Saskatoon thanks so much for watching
and hope you'll join us again tomorrow
have a great
night
[Music]